albert breer from sports illustrated
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you doing oh by the way we had to get
our own a b right hey that's right
your shirt's on right albert exactly
yeah my my shirt's on i hope i'm a
little bit more stable um i just want to
check on you rich well make sure
everything's okay six days out now
oh wow
yeah
yeah
wow
[Music]
that's coming from somebody who knows
what it feels like we uh i don't care i
i thirty-one is nothing against clemson
all right so i've been there before i've
been there before it's okay albert it's
a first place big ten season with a
42-point game against your alma mater
it's that's always up on the board and
it's going to be there for at least
another
you know
forever and ever but you know 300 days
another 300 days it's okay
but i like that you come out firing
albert i just love that you have just
zero
zero chill and shame
fantastic same as it ever was
yeah well we made some we've made some
coaching changes in the afternoon we'll
see how all that plays out
well let's get to the uh task at hand
here um
so
um
about money huh is that what this was
about or what yeah
is that what this means
i mean i you know and i i heard a little
bit of your preamble there and you know
i i just think it's
it's this constant thought that like you
know and i think a lot of times you know
coaches and players can convince
themselves this that when the guy gets
into our environment it's going to be
different and um you know i i i hesitate
to say it's just about money because if
it's not one thing it's the other with
the guy you know what i mean like so
we can get down to the details and we
can talk about the injury and the
disagreement over why he left the
sideline where the truth is whether
whether he was hurt that we're going to
hear different versions of that but the
truth is rich
it's just always something you know and
you know if you want to go back to how
he wound up
blowing out of blowing his way out of
pittsburgh it was over losing a team mvp
award to juju's miss schuster a guy who
was in his position group room won the
team mvp and that pissed him off
sufficiently that he blew his way out of
a place that he had been for nine years
in oakland it was the weird thing with
the helmet and the feet and all that and
then in new england it was
um you know basically
publicly taking shots at ownership after
he had been there for a total of eight
or nine days so
um you know i i i think it's hard to
look at this situation based on the
history that's here and say that it's
anything else but antonio brown being
antonio brown and it's over right or or
what's the aftermath of this
i mean it's over in terms of them
talking about it but what is the
aftermath of all this well i mean i'm bo
what's let's let's let's do the player
side first i mean i i have to think this
is the end of antonio brown's career i i
just wow that's it yeah really really i
just i i like he said he's going to get
surgery and when he comes back from
surgery he'll be what i got to look at
how old he is but he's in his 30s
um and i just
i mean like look like i think you have
to kind of look at each of these
situations and you know in the previous
situations you could maybe couch it one
way or the other you know in pittsburgh
it's well you know he's he's sick of of
being there and he wanted a new start in
oakland he could say they weren't
winning in new england you could say
well that's a stringent environment i
mean
in tampa he he won a super bowl there
right like he had a chance to win
another one the quarterback despite what
he says had his back 100 through
everything and kept giving him
opportunities and kept wanting to work
him into the offense more and bruce
arians runs maybe the most
player-friendly culture in the nfl right
the players have a huge part in running
that team
and i i think if you're another team you
have to look at that and say if it's not
going to work if it wasn't going to work
there
like who are we to say that it's going
to work where we're at you know like i
don't know how anybody could look at
that and think
like with a change of scenery this guy's
going to be different so
i just think it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be hard for him to find a job
anywhere after this um you know as for
the team i do think it's a blow you know
if this had happened last year
i don't think it would have been as big
a deal like last year like both him and
gronkowski were sort of like bonus
weapons because it was a covered year
because those guys came in late because
everything was sort of
um you know like
they they did things to incorporate
those guys but they weren't really
integrated into the offense this time
around
when they went to that month where they
didn't win a game um rich and brady kind
of was up and down and struggled a
little bit
you know a big part of that was that
that that gronk and a b were out you
know and and so you know i think those
both those guys
have become such integral parts to what
the bucks are offensively because of
their relationship with the quarterback
because the quarterback trusts them and
so
you know i think this year you know you
add you know all that that i just said
to the fact they're all already down
chris godwin and i actually think on the
football field it's a pretty significant
loss for the box albert breer here on
the rich eisen show senior nfl reporter
from the mmqb of sports illustrated um
on on our program so uh the quarterback
that will grab the most headlines in the
off season that is essentially started
for so many
who's it going to be what do you got for
me on that front what do you crystal
ball it is it rogers is it i'll give you
is it is it desean watson russell baker
what do you got for me honestly i mean i
think we're it's it feels like maybe
what we thought was going to happen last
year might happen this year with you
know some dominoes as far as the
quarterbacks go
um you know i actually think
i think the packers are going to win the
super bowl so
i if the packers win the super bowl i
think you've sort of subtly heard aaron
rodgers tone changing a little bit um in
several different places like the way he
talked about brian gouda koontz i think
the appreciation the emotion you saw
after he broke brett favre's record
right like and kind of like how he had
this appreciation for for where he is
and and getting to play in lambeau and
so
i actually think there's a potential
there that that aaron rodgers has a new
new contract with the packers and winds
up staying there in
um so i'd say like watson
and and wilson will probably be the two
you know watson obviously you know i
think his legal situation plays into
everything they've been they've been
waiting to move him and and i think he
will be moved and i think there if if
there's clarity in the legal situation
there's gonna be a huge market for
deshaun watson out there you know and
then i think with russell wilson maybe
it plays out like you know things deal
with matthew stafford last year
depending on what happens you know pete
carroll and john schneider there i could
certainly see
them having a meeting and
you know i kind of like like i said like
what what happened with stafford and
detroit they sort of negotiate a clean
break so then wilson and watson are out
there and then i think you know on the
kind of the secondary level baker
mayfield jimmy garoppolo you know the
derek carr situation in vegas is sort of
interesting because next year will be a
contract year for him but i would think
the raiders try to try to lock up
derek carr long term um so you know i
think you not only have like the big box
pieces but the guys like wilson and
watson out there but you also have you
know the second layer of quarterbacks
that could wind up becoming available
what is the plan for baker mayfield in
cleveland now
you know i i think the way that the
browns are looking at it this is just my
sense of it um you know going into the
year it was do we pay him at the top of
the market and part of the problem race
is that there's no like b level um you
know quarterback contract out there to
work off of
and so like you know that's why you know
a lot of these decisions have become yes
or no um you know do you believe the
guy's a franchise guy or not and if you
do you pay him at the top of the market
if you don't then you wind up letting
them go
um and i i think right now if you're the
browns you have a hard time wrapping
your your head yeah paying baker
mayfield 40 or 45 million dollars a year
um you know and then i think if you're
not going to do that you got to ask
yourself the very real question can we
go through the awkwardness of
like playing out his fifth year option
here
where it was already awkward a little
bit this year you know with some of the
stuff that happened on instagram and
everything else
and so you know my guess is you know
they're going to look at it they're
going to say if we aren't willing to pay
baker 40 million dollars a year let's
see if there's a quarterback out there
that we are willing to give that money
to
so you know i think you know that the
browns will at least investigate watson
i think they'll at least investigate
wilson rogers too if he winds up being
out there
um and you know i think they view
themselves as being in very much a
win-now window um you know where it's
um you know like i think the roth they
feel like they're rosters right there
and so you know the question becomes can
they land one of those guys and if they
can't
do they stick with baker or do they
maybe go with some sort of band-aid for
right now where it would be a little bit
less awkward than bringing baker back in
the contract here and maybe that winds
up being something like jimmy garoppolo
wouldn't it be uh what's the word ironic
or
uh interesting
however you want to put it uh that the
browns would do that but can't land one
of those guys because the steelers do
right is that the steel is that the
steelers plan too what you just kind of
laid out
yeah i mean i don't think the steelers
have really i don't think the steelers
know exactly what they're to do yet like
i think part part of the issue that
steelers have is
um they're depleted to some degree from
a draft pick standpoint and and their
cap is a little bit of a mess going into
next year
and so you know i i think with the
steelers
you know the question is do you want to
do like a full reset at the position and
and draft a rookie and start over that
way
do you want like a band-aid you know and
and maybe that's like a ryan fitzpatrick
or someone like that like jimmy
garoppolo
or
um you know do you do you want to take
the big swing and the big swing again
would require capital that they don't
necessarily have right now maybe they
can create it but they don't have it
right now and that hasn't generally been
their way and so
um you know i think it feels to me like
the most likely scenario like what they
would like to do is go into the draft
find a rookie to replace ben
roethlisberger with the issue with that
of course is that i mean you look at
this year's group rich and there's not
like a trevor like like last year the
five guys right like lawrence fields
wilson
uh lance and jones
like i i don't know that there's a
single quarterback in this year's draft
that would crack that group like whoever
the number one guy is i think would
probably have gone sixth last year
and so you know that's going to be the
question for a lot of these quarterback
needy teams which could drive up the
market for the veterans
is is there a rookie out there that we
think can be a real difference maker for
us and you know we'll see if kenny
pickett and matt corral and
malik willis and you know all these guys
that are going to be going into the
draft can can can can work over the
three or four months to come to drive
their stock north but as it stands right
now
i think they're going to be more than a
few teams that are going to go into the
draft cycle without a single first round
grade on any of the quarterbacks albert
breer here on the rich eisen show and on
the coaching front an interesting name
that might be interested in getting a
gig is jim harbaugh interested in going
back to the
league where he had 44 wins and took a
team to the super bowl and almost won it
in the same league where urban meyer is
now the standard for the biggest triple
lindy flop and biggest blown opportunity
in the history of coaching
so
uh
no no it's okay it's i i i everything i
just said is factually correct it is
true okay uh what do you think is
harbaugh uh he interested and do you
think their that interest could be
mutual
yeah here's where here's what i think
rich i i know um
you know i what i know about jim from
having covered him all those years ago
you know when he was in san francisco
uh he tends to hold grudges and
like i i don't know that there was i
don't know that he was as happy about
taking the pay cut last year right as
like he may have let on
and so
if he can make michigan squirm and not
seeing the school in general i mean like
i don't mean it that way the people who
if he can make if he can make the people
who made him take the pay cut squirm a
little bit
and
[Music]
maybe
get like get like like make them a
little uncomfortable and then wind up
getting a new contract out of it like i
don't think that'd be a horrible result
for him right like and maybe you know as
part of that you work in some sort of
like nil deal where we're going to do
this and this and this to help you get
players everything else so
i think that that's one possibility um
yeah the other possibility is that he
was sufficiently pissed off last year
where
he does want to look around and by the
way like when there was a question about
his future last year i can tell you
like he like intermediaries put his name
in front of several nfl teams and there
was an interest then but based on how
he's bounced back this year
i think you know at least from a team or
two there at least be a curiosity
um so you know we'll see i can't tell
you what his intention is but
um you know i certainly don't think he's
done much to shoot down the idea of the
possibility and uh you know it's going
to be an interesting interesting couple
weeks here to see what happens with him
uh because obviously he had great
success at the nfl level um you know and
i and i do think that like to some
degree getting that close to winning a
super bowl and and not getting there
does leave like a bit of an unfinished
business for him at the nfl level and
then you had a great piece this week
about um
trevor lawrence uh because amongst all
the the many reasons why urban meyer
flamed out in such a spectacular face
plant fashion albert
um from
you know kicking his kicker to
um you know not taking the flight back
from cincinnati and what he was doing in
ohio after not taking the flight back
from cincinnati is that
the one guy who was evaluated is the
most sure-fire prospect coming into the
nfl is leaving his first season in the
nfl essentially potentially not able to
be evaluated albert
and yeah and so you you had uh quite a
piece on that i want to give you the
floor on what you found out about what
people think of trevor lawrence's first
year in viability moving forward for
jacksonville yeah sure so i you know i i
talked to you know a number of different
scouts coaches that have played against
them this year you know so these are
guys that have actually like looked at
him and evaluated the tape and you know
i i there were you know obviously like
you're taking everything into account
when you're doing that so the first
thing all these guys said the situation
around him wasn't good but they didn't
do enough creatively to get the most out
of them
the skill talent out around him wasn't
very good losing djhr you know was it
was a big deal um because they didn't
have a ton to threaten defenses with to
begin with so there's all that
um but there were also some things that
i think you know at least
raised some concern the first was the
ability to process and how quickly he
sees the field and you know i i think
part of the evaluation of clemson wasn't
that he couldn't do it it was that you
didn't see him do it and then at clemson
the offense is sort of simple
and it was designed to have the
quarterback get the ball out really
quickly um and he really wasn't going
through full field reads there and so
you know what teams have sort of noticed
watching him is man he's a little slower
processing than we thought he would be
like he's not seeing it as fast as we
would like
that's something that can be learned
over time
but it's something that definitely
showed up like the processing wasn't
like as fast as you'd hope it would be
coming out of college um then the second
thing was you know his athleticism
hasn't translated to to the nfl the same
way some people thought it would and you
watched him enough at clemson to know
rich like he was a real run threat you
know like yeah like he made a lot of
plays with his feet um at the college
level yeah and that 31 to nothing win as
a matter of fact if i'm not mistaken no
no no no no no no no no no no
my bad okay yeah my bad
but we did wind up getting we did wind
up getting him um yeah so but i've been
i mean like that that that that that
ability
to
create on your own to create yardage to
to to escape to
to to buy time to throw
like it just hasn't translated it as
much and maybe that's just not being as
comfortable
um with it with with what you're doing
and everything around you the same way
he was at clemson um or you know maybe
it's just you know like it's everybody's
bigger and faster and stronger around
you and it's a little harder to get away
than it was so
i think if you add all of it up you know
rich is like
you know look i'm the first to say like
i i remember talking i talked to scouts
for about him for for two and a half
years and it was always like this guy is
the next you know peyton manning john
elway andrew lucky's in that category
um you know what i'm getting back now is
yeah he's a little more raw than we
thought so the talent's there but when
you add up everything that i just said
it's just there's
like he is
sort of more of prospect than ready-made
player if that makes sense so who gets
the golden ticket that urban torched who
gets the golden ticket you think
to coach him to coach him well i mean
part of the problem part of the problem
rich is
um that they are keeping their general
manager in place
and you know like that issue
has already come up you know and in my
conversations over the last two weeks
um there are coaches who flat out aren't
going to go there because uh because
trent valkyrie's there and that's with
you know a generational type of prospect
and trevor lawrence with the position
wow um and so it's i mean it that that's
part of the issue right now is like
they're kind of like sorting through
things and it's you know there are
coaches that just just flat out aren't
going to go there because of what
happened with trent in san francisco and
because he has a certain reputation
of you know i mean let's call it what is
like people think he stabbed a bunch of
people in san francisco in the back and
that
that it's already happened in
jacksonville some too so
um you know if they're going to hang on
to trent as a general manager
they're going to have to sort of
overcome that with whoever they they
hire as their coach now i will say this
like
one thing i have gotten back already is
they do plan on making this a a pretty
extensive search and that
like last year they're going to do the
opposite of what they did last year
where last year we knew what they were
doing from the start and they targeted
one guy and they went and got him this
year i think they really want to go into
it and talk to a lot of people and
they've already talked to a lot of
people and kind of go through a full
process and make a decision that way and
i mean two of the names that you hear
early on and guys that have already
talked to them or jim caldwell and doug
peterson and obviously both those guys
have extensive history working with
quarterbacks so that would be a plus but
i think more than anything else like you
know finding somebody who can come in
and sort of calm things down and what's
been a pretty chaotic after what's been
a pretty chaotic year is job number one
well albert i appreciate you calling in
and accepting my invitation to come on
not only because i always appreciate you
and your information is impeccable in
the way delivered it's terrific but you
were also curious to check on me about
me in the last six days even though
we've been texting non-stop in the
internet so thank you albert i
appreciate it thank you
thank you i'm glad you're i'm glad
you're doing one thanks but you knew
that hey hey hey hey in all seriousness
yeah uh congrats on a great year like
seriously like that uh you know i i as
somebody who knows how it feels to go
through years like that congratulations
i'm sure it was a
fantastic year
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
after hitting a triple with his
information very good thank you albert
thank you appreciate it i think i've
been home before
goodbye albert
thanks for calling
have a prayer everybody hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here